[Music]
make room earthling
we're moving the other planets in our
solar system into our planetary neck of
the woods
would all the planets fit into this
goldilocks zone
what kinds of gravitational chaos would
this cause
and does this mean life would exist on
the other planets
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all the planets of the solar
system were in the habitable zone
liquid water is a key ingredient for
life and in our solar system
earth is the only planet with liquid
water on its surface
that's because our planet is located in
the habitable zone of our sun
also known as the goldilocks zone and
the conditions here are
just
right
any closer and water would boil away
any further it would freeze
the size of this area depends on how hot
or cool a star is
scientists have discovered 4 000
exoplanets within habitable zones but
only 24 of them might be able to support
life
in our solar system this zone is within
a range of 0.9 to 1.2 astronomical units
from the sun
so if we parked all the other planets
within this 45 million kilometer patch
of real estate
could we kickstart
extraterrestrial life
hey i don't know about extraterrestrial
life but my life sure needs some changes
this year
did you know that 80 percent of new
year's resolutions are abandoned in the
first two months well that won't happen
to me because i'm now using fabulous
fabulous is an award-winning app that
breaks down healthy habits into small
tasks that i can easily achieve whether
i want to work out more increase
productivity or find time to read
fabulous helps create routines for
habits meant to change behavior and keep
you motivated throughout your life
there's no shortcut here just a fabulous
and proven way to begin your guided
journey to success and if you still
think you don't know where to start
fabulous has you covered they offer
guided habit tracking with daily
coaching sessions to help you get your
day started and unwind in the evening
you're never on this path alone and the
first 100 people who visit the link
below will get 25
off a premium subscription so begin your
new routine today and visit thefab.co
what if take advantage of this offer and
start creating healthy habits to make
your resolutions last all year
as you're about to see changing your
life is one thing but
making life from nothing
might be even tougher
with eight planets to squeeze in the
goldilocks zone
you'd need to get creative the last
thing you'd want to do would be disrupt
the conditions for life on earth right
well to start this scenario off you'd
need to move mercury to the innermost
portion of the habitable zone
at around 0.9 astronomical units
that would be more than twice as far
away from the sun as mercury orbits now
not much would change on this rocky
planet except for a refreshing coolness
after billions of years of scorching hot
temperatures
venus already orbits relatively close to
the habitable zone at
0.72 astronomical units
when our son was a young star and dimmer
venus was essentially located in a
habitable zone
it could even have had conditions for
life with a shallow ocean of its own
but as the sun got hotter that
goldilocks zone was pushed further back
temperatures increased and the oceans
boiled away
maybe relocating venus to a cooler spot
away from the sun could make it
habitable once again
now it would be time to do some
calculating
you've got five more planets to squeeze
in it could be a good idea to make sure
all the planets are an equal distance
apart
with our narrow goldilocks zone you
could place each planet six and a half
million kilometers from each other
that would be equal to about 30 times
the distance between the earth and the
moon
moving us away from our current location
would make this whole experiment a
little less chaotic but at about 0.97
astronomical units
things would get warmer here
bad news for the climate crisis
uh ignoring that for now you'd move on
to mars
you'd be excited to see if this cold
rocky planet could have life
well
sorry to say
it would still be barren
you see liquid water isn't the only
thing that life needs to thrive
mars lacks a magnetic field
that means solar radiation would strip
away the chances of it having an
atmosphere
you'd still have to terraform it
you'd likely not see any life popping up
on the remaining gaseous planets either
the gas giants jupiter and saturn have
atmospheric pressures and temperatures
far too intense for molecules like dna
to be stable
but you could probably take a cold dip
on one of jupiter's moons europa
its new proximity to the sun would allow
its thick ice layer to melt
feeling refreshed you'd realize that the
last planet in our solar system neptune
is now even closer to us than mars is
today
that means in our new solar system
arrangement planet hopping would be a
reasonable adventure
even with current technology you could
travel between the planets in 90 days
and beyond the exploration there are all
kinds of resources you could extract
from the other planets
you could get hydrogen fuel from jupiter
and saturn to help us transition to a
low-carbon future
you could mine cobalt from asteroids
this would be important to developing
renewable energy systems
but
this new solar system would be a little
unstable to say the least
especially with a massive planet like
jupiter so close to us
it has two and a half times the mass of
all the other planets in our solar
system combined
scientific reports indicate a star
similar to our sun
could have six earth-sized planets
within its habitable zone
with jupiter gravitational stability
would be all out of whack and all these
imbalances could result in the planets
or moons getting ejected from orbit or
reshuffled completely
maybe you'd end up with a messy new
order of planets
and life on earth facing extinction
but
that's a story
for another
what if